The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good morning, everybody.
Welcome to lecture 12 of A286.
I can't think of any
announcements for today,
but let me begin
by asking if there
are any questions either about
logistics or about physics.
OK.
In that case, let's get started.
I want to begin by having a
rapid run through of the things
we talked about last time
just to firm everything
up in our minds and
get us ready to go on.
So, last time we were talking
about non-euclidean geometry
in a serious way.
We began by considering the
surface of a sphere, just
a two-dimensional
sphere embedded
in a three-dimensional
space, described
by the simple equation x squared
plus y squared plus z squared
equals R squared.
We said that if we wanted to
talk about the surface itself,
we'd want to have
coordinates for the surface
and not just speak of things
in terms of x, y, and z.
So we introduced the
standard polar coordinates--
theta and phi, which
are related to x, y,
and z by these fairly
well-known equations.
Then we wanted to
know the metric
in terms of our new
variables theta and phi,
which is the main goal--
to figure out the metric.
So we first considered
varying the two variables one
at a time.
By varying theta, we see
that the point described
by theta phi would sweep out
a circle whose radius is R,
and the angle
subtended is d theta.
So the arc length is
just R times d theta.
So for varying
theta, the arc length
is given by that
simple equation.
Similarly, we went
on to ask ourselves
what happens when we vary phi.
As we vary phi, the
point described by theta
comma phi again
sweeps out a circle,
but this time it's a circle
in the horizontal plane whose
radius is not R but whose
radius has this projection
factor that's R
times sine theta.
So the angle is
again-- excuse me,
the arc length is again d phi,
the angles, times the radius,
but the radius is R sine theta.
So ds, the total arc length,
is R times sine theta d phi.
Then, to put them
together, we notice
that these two variations are
orthogonal to each other, which
you could see pretty
directly from the diagram.
So if we do both of
them at the same time
and ask what's the total
length of the displacement,
it's just a simple application
of the Pythagorean theorem.
And we get the sum
of the squares.
So, varying theta
gives us Rd theta.
Varying phi gives us
R sine theta d phi.
And putting them
together, we just
get ds squared is the sum of
the squares of those, which
is R squared times d theta
squared plus sine squared
theta d phi squared.
And that's the standard
metric for the service
of a sphere in
polar coordinates.
So that was a warm up.
What we really want to do is to
elevate that problem one more
dimension, and then we have
a model for the universe.
We can use the same
method to construct
a three-dimensional space, which
is a three-dimensional surface
of a sphere embedded in
four euclidean dimensions,
and that becomes a perfectly
viable homogeneous,
isotropic, non-euclidean metric
that can describe a universe
and, in particular,
describes the type
of universe called
a closed universe.
So to do that, we
introduce one more axis, w.
And we consider the sphere
described by x squared plus y
squared plus z squared plus
w squared equals R squared.
So it's a
three-dimensional surface
of a sphere in four dimensions.
We then need to introduce
one more variable
to describe points
on the surface,
and we introduce this in
the form of a new angle.
The new angle I
chose to call psi.
And we measure that angle from
the new axis, from the w-axis.
So the new angle psi
is simply the angle
from the w-axis, which
means that the projection
of our vector from the origin
to the point in the w direction
is just the R cosine psi and
the projection into the x, y, z
subspace is R times sine psi.
And the four equations that
describe x, y, z, and w
are shown there.
And all we did is we set the
w-coordinate equal to R times
cosine psi, which is
just the statement
that psi measures the
angle from the w-axis.
Nothing more.
And then we multiplied x, y,
and z by a factor of sine psi,
so that now we still have
maintained the condition that x
squared plus y squared plus
z squared plus w squared
is equal to R squared,
which you can prove directly
by manipulating this using
the famous identity sine
squared plus cosine
squared equals 1.
Nothing more profound than that.
So, we're now ready to go
ahead and find the new metric,
and this time it'll really be
something nontrivial, something
you didn't already
know from high school.
The new displacement
is to vary psi.
If we vary psi, it's
really the same story
as we've seen before except
in a different plane.
ds is just equal
to R times d psi.
I guess, as we
vary psi, the point
described by these coordinates
makes a full circle of radius
R.
OK, now what we want to do
is put all this together.
If we vary psi, we know that ds
is equal to R times deep psi.
If we just vary
theta or phi, it's
the same thing we had before.
We don't need to rethink it.
All we need to do
is remember there's
an extra factor of sine psi
in front of all [INAUDIBLE]
in the XYZ subspace.
So if you vary theta
or phi, ds squared
is just equal to what we
had before for the metric
multiplied by the extra
factor of sine squared of psi.
Then to put them together,
if we assume for the moment
that they are orthogonal
to each other,
then we just add the
sum of the squares.
And that is the right answer.
But I'll justify it in a minute.
But jumping ahead and
making the assumption
that these separate
displacements are always
orthogonal to each
other, ds squared
is then just the
sum of the squares,
and we get this matrix to
describe our closed universe
in terms of the variables
psi, theta, and phi.
To prove this
orthogonality, which
is crucial for
believing that result,
I gave an argument
last time, and I'll
outline again on
the slides here.
We can consider the two
displacement vectors
that we're trying to
show to be orthogonal.
dR sub psi is a
four-dimensional vector,
which represents the
displacement of the point being
described by these coordinates
when psi is changed
to psi plus deep psi,
infinitesimal change in the psi
coordinate.
Similarly, I'm going
to let dR sub theta be
the displacement vector
that the point described
by these coordinates
undergoes when theta is varied
by an infinitesimal
amount, d theta.
And what we're trying to
show is that these two
are orthogonal to each other.
So if we do them both, the
magnitude of the change
is just the sum of
squares, the square root
of the sum of squares.
So, first looking
at dR sub theta,
we notice that dR sub
theta has no w-component.
And to make that clear,
we should go back a couple
slides and look at
how w is defined.
w is defined as R
times cosine psi.
So if we vary theta,
w doesn't change.
It doesn't depend on theta.
So if dR sub theta
has no w-component,
it means that when we take
the dot product of dR psi
with the dR theta,
we want to show
that this is 0 to show
that they're orthogonal.
The w-components won't
enter, because one of the two
w-components is 0,
and the dot product
is a sum of the product
of the x-components
plus the product
of the y-components
of the z-components
plus the product of
the w-components.
So w-compontents only
enter as a product
of the two w-components.
So as long as one of them is 0,
there's no contribution there.
So the four-dimensional
dot product
reduces to a
three-dimensional dot product.
And here I'm introducing
a peculiar notation
when I put a subscript--
a superscript, rather-- 3
in a vector.
I just mean take the
first three components
and ignore the fourth and
think of it as a 3 vector.
So the dot product that
we're trying to calculate now
is just the dot product
of two 3 vectors--
the one that we get when
we vary psi and the one
that we get when we vary theta.
Next thing to notice
is that we can
look at the properties
of these two vectors.
And dR psi, the vector we
get when we vary psi, I claim
is in the radial direction
in this three-dimensional
subspace.
And we can see that
by looking again
at these formulas
that relate the angles
to the Cartesian coordinates.
When we vary psi,
sine psi changes,
but sine psi multiplies x, y,
and z all by the same amount.
So sine psi changes.
It changes x, y, and
z proportionally.
And if you change x, y,
and z proportionally,
it means you're moving
in the radial direction
in this three-dimensional
subspace.
On the other hand, dR theta is
what we get when we vary theta.
And from the
beginning, theta was
defined in a way that
parametrized the sphere.
So varying theta only
moves you along the sphere.
It does not change your
distance from the origin.
So varying theta is
purely tangential.
So we have a dot product
between a radial vector
and a tangential vector,
and those are always
orthogonal to each other.
So we get a dot product
of 0, as claimed.
So the two original
four vectors are
orthogonal to each other, which
is what we're trying to prove.
OK, everybody happy with that?
It is a crucial step.
You haven't really
gotten the results
unless you know these
vectors are orthogonal.
OK, almost done now.
We then later in lecture
talked about the implications
of general relativity,
and here we
didn't prove what
we were claiming.
We just admitted that
there are some things
in general relativity that we're
just going to have to assume,
and this really is
almost the only one.
General relativity tells us how
matter causes space to curve.
And it does that in the
form of what are called
the Einstein field equations.
And we're not going to learn
That's the subject of a
general relativity course.
So we're just going
to have to assume
what general relativity tells
us about how space curves,
and in particular in this
instance, what it tells
us is that the radius of
curvature R-- this R that we've
introduced into our metric--
is the radius of curvature
of the space, is related to the
matter and motion by R squared
being equal to a squared
of t divided by k.
And we did argue last time
that, that k in the denominator
really is necessary just to
make the units turn out right.
So we really know by
dimensional analysis
that this formula has to
hold up to some factor.
The fact that the
factor is 1 is a fact
about general relativity,
which we're not
showing at this point.
When one puts this
back into the metric
to express the metric
in terms of a of t,
we find finally
that the metric can
be written as shown
in the box here,
and this is the
last equation, where
I've made a substitution
of variables.
I replaced the angle psi by
a radial coordinate little r,
which is defined
to be sine of psi
divided by the square root of k.
And this form of
the metric is what's
called the
Robertson-Walker metric.
And it's a famous
form of the metric.
This is what people
normally use.
So that finishes everything
we said last time, I think.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What is the motivation
for saying that the-- where
you can describe space as
a three-dimensional sphere
in a four space.
Is it because it's only
real geometry that,
where there's
isotropian [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
I was going to be saying
that shortly, but yes.
This metric and its open
universe counterpart
and flat space together
make up the most general
possible metric, which is
homogeneous and isotropic.
At this stage, I'm
really not going
to claim that anyway,
but at this stage,
what we do know is
that this metric is
homogeneous and isotropic.
And certainly what we're
trying to construct
is metrics, which are
homogeneous and isotropic.
But this also is actually
the only possibility
within that small class.
Any other questions?
OK.
In that case, we will
continue on the blackboard.
So what we have
derived so far is
the metric for a
closed universe.
Maybe I'll start by
getting on the blackboard
the same formula
that's up there, just
so I can see it better.
Even though you can probably
see equally well either way.
A closed universe is
described by ds squared
is equal to a squared of t
times dr squared over 1 minus kr
squared plus r squared d theta
squared plus sine squared theta
d phi squared.
And to relate this variable r
to our previous definitions,
little r is equal
to the sine of psi
divided by the square root of k.
OK.
Question back there?
AUDIENCE: Psi is-- sorry this
is just [INAUDIBLE] think.
Psi is which angle?
PROFESSOR: OK, the question
is psi is which angle.
Psi is the angle
we introduced when
we went from two-dimension
sphere embedded in three
dimensions to one
dimension higher.
Psi is the angle
from the new axis.
The angle from the w axis.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, we've covered a
lot of ground here.
We have our first
non-euclidean metric
that's visibly important.
But we know from our work on the
Newtonian model of the universe
that this little k doesn't
have to be positive.
It can be positive,
negative, or 0.
If k is 0, the
metric is actually
just the metric of a flat space.
But when k is
negative, it's a case
that we haven't
talked about yet.
So we want to know, what
will we write for a metric
if k were negative?
And the answer to that turns
out to be perfectly simple.
This formula has a k in it.
Lots of times in
our experience--
I'm sure we all know-- when
we write an equation for one
sine of a variable, we
find that the same equation
works even if the variable
has the other sine.
So if you're buying and selling
stocks, if the stocks go up
and the stocks go down, you
can use the same equations.
The price today is the price
yesterday plus the increment,
and the increment could
be positive or negative.
But that equation-- price
today equals price yesterday
plus income-- it still works.
And same thing here.
If k it happens to
be negative, there's
nothing wrong with this formula.
It, in fact, describes an
open universe just as well
as it describes a
closed universe.
Now notice, however, that
things are a little bit tricky.
If you look at the equation that
I wrote immediately below here,
if k is negative, we
have the square root
of a negative number here,
so the denominator would
be imaginary, and what would
that say about r and psi?
It would obviously confuse us.
So you really have to write
the metric and the correct form
before you can just
change the sign of k.
If we had written the
metric in terms of psi
and not made the substitution,
we could just as well
have written the metric
for a closed universe
as a squared of t divided
by k times d psi squared
plus sine squared psi d theta
squared plus sine squared
theta d phi squared.
This is an alternative metric
for the closed universe.
It's, in fact, where we started.
We then made a substitution,
replacing sine psi by little r.
If we had the metric in
this form and we said,
well, let k be negative
instead of positive,
then notice that a squared
is certainly positive,
so we'd have a negative number
out here times things which
are also manifestly positive.
We would have a
negative definite metric
instead of a positive
definite metric.
So we could not change the sign
of little k in this formula
and get what we want.
So you have to careful.
It doesn't always work.
But it does work when you
write the metric in this form.
Now since it
doesn't always work,
and since we haven't really
made any sound arguments yet,
I'd like to spend a
little time describing--
I'm not going to do the
calculation because it's
too messy, but I'd
like spend little time
describing how you would
show that this metric works
for an open universe.
So first thing to
recognize is-- what
do we actually mean
when we say it "works"?
Can somebody tell me what I
probably mean when I say that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't have
any glaring contradictions?
PROFESSOR: Doesn't have
any glaring contradictions.
Yeah, that's good, but we can
be more specific, especially
since I'm going to try to
describe how we would actually
show it, and it's a little hard
to show that something doesn't
have glaring contradictions.
What do we actually care about
in constructing these metrics?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does the goal
that they hold well
in limits, i.e.,
the flat universes?
PROFESSOR: That the physics will
hold well in certain limits,
like they should approach
the flat universe and limit.
We certainly do
want that to happen,
but there is
something else that we
want that doesn't
involve taking limits,
because you have
different things which
all approach the same
limit, of course.
Making sure an answer approaches
the right limits is a good way
to test the answer, because
most wrong answers will not
have the right limits.
But merely knowing you
have the right limits
does not prove that you
have the right answer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It could also reflect
an isotropic and homogeneous
non-euclidean?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Exactly.
What we're looking for is
a homogeneous and isotropic
non-euclidean space,
because that's
what we know about our universe.
It's homogeneous and
isotropic, and we're
trying to build a mathematical
model of those facts.
So we want homogeneity
and isotropy.
If we limit isotropy to
isotropy about the origin, which
is enough if we're going to
later prove homogeneity, which
will prove that all
points are equivalent,
isotropy about the
origin is obvious here,
because the angular part
is just exactly what we
had for a sphere in three
euclidean dimensions.
So it behaves on angles exactly
like a euclidean problem,
so we know that it's isotropic.
If you point out
that algebraically
as you look at it, it's not
obvious that it's isotropic.
We just know where that
expression came from.
It came from the sphere.
In terms of theta and phi,
it's not manifestly isotropic.
And that's because in
choosing theta and phi,
we chose a special
point, the North Pole,
to measure our angle theta from.
And the choice of that special
point for our coordinate system
broke the isotropy.
But we know that deep
down it is isotropic.
And that idea, that you can have
such isotropy without having
manifest isotropy is
also crucial to how
homogeneity plays
out in this metric.
I claim, and we know
really, that this metric
is homogeneous.
At least we know
where it came from.
It came, again, from
the surface of a sphere
one dimension higher than
just the angular part.
And then spherical picture--it's
obviously homogeneous.
But nonetheless, in building
our coordinate system,
we had to break the homogeneity.
We chose a special
point-- again,
what we might call
the North Pole--
in this case, the point
where w has its maximum value
and made that point special.
The point where w had its
maximum value in the x, y, z, w
space is the point
which is now the origin
of this coordinate system.
So, if we wanted to prove
that this metric really
is homogeneous, we
would like to prove it
for the k equals minus 1 case.
But let's first,
imaging, what would we
do if we wanted to prove
that it was homogeneous
for the k equals plus 1
case or k positive case?
The case that we really
think we do understand.
The closed universe.
For the closed universe, this
does not look homogeneous.
It looks like the
origin is special.
r equals 0 is special.
But we know that it
came from the sphere,
and if somebody asked us to
prove that, that metric was
homogeneous-- more
particularly, somebody
might, for example,
challenge us to construct
a coordinate transformation,
which would preserve the metric
and map some arbitrary point r
0 theta 0 phi 0 to the origin.
We might undertake
that challenge.
It's a lot of work.
We're not going
to actually do it.
And I promise I'll
never ask you to do it.
But I want to talk a little
bit about how we would do it,
because we do have a method,
which we know will work.
And knowing that we
have a method that works
is all we really need to know.
So suppose we wanted a
coordinate transformation
that preserves the
form of the metric
and maps some arbitrary
point, and I'll
give the coordinates to
this arbitrary point a name.
I'll call it r 0,
theta 0, and phi 0.
These are coordinates
of a point.
So we're going to map this
arbitrary point to the origin.
Notice that this is a concrete
statement about homogeneity.
If we can map an arbitrary
point to the origin
while preserving
the metric, we're
really proving that
an arbitrary point
is equivalent to the origin.
And if an arbitrary point
is equivalent to the origin,
then all points are
equivalent to the origin
and equivalent to each other.
We're done.
That proves homogeneity.
So, suppose we
wanted to do this.
How would we do it?
The point is that knowing how we
got this metric from the sphere
allows us to go back to
sphere and rotate the sphere
and rotate back and derive
the coordinate transformation
that we want.
And I'll just describe that
in slightly more detail.
What we would first
do is-- I claim
we can do it in three
steps, each of which
we know how to do
although they're messy.
I guess I'll start over here.
So step one is to find
the x, y, z, w-coordinates
that go with this point.
Because once we have the
x, y, z, w-coordinates,
we're in our
four-dimensional space
where we know how
to do rotations.
So the first thing
we do is we just find
the corresponding x, y, z,
w-coordinates where x0 is just
the x-coordinate that goes
with r0, theta0, and phi0.
And y0 is the y-coordinate that
goes with r0, theta0, and phi0.
And z0 is the z-coordinate,
and w0 is the w-coordinate.
And these are just
points we had before.
I'm writing them
symbolically, but we
know how to express the
Cartesian coordinates
in terms of the angles.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do we
have a psi0 as well?
PROFESSOR: r0 replaced psi0.
r0 is the sine of psi
divided by root k.
So we only need
three coordinates.
We could have different
choices of what we call them.
We could've used psi here.
The reason I'm using little r is
that I want to, when I'm done,
describe what we would
do if k were a negative.
And if k were a
negative, we already
said that psi does
not actually work.
We have to use different
coordinates in order
to smoothly write an open
universe coordinate system.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How is that
not like cheating?
Because, I mean, you did
define r with the root k,
and now we're just
kind of ignoring them.
PROFESSOR: Well that's
exactly-- the question
is why is this not cheating?
And the reason it's
not cheating is
because of what I'm
about to show you.
What I'm saying really is
that just setting k negative
is something you might
expect to probably work.
I think you have good grounds
to expect it to probably work.
Now what we're
talking about is how
to actually show that it works.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Professor,
what's the necessity
of defining w as opposed
to, I don't know, t?
The traditional, like, t--
PROFESSOR: OK.
The question is why did I call
the fourth variable w and not
t.
The answer is that the variable
we're talking about here
is not time.
It's another spatial coordinate.
So, for that reason
I think it's better
to call it w than to call it t.
Of course, needless to
say, the name of a variable
doesn't have any
actual significance.
So I certainly could have
called it t equally well,
but I think that would have
caused some confusion by people
thinking it was
time, which it's not.
Any other questions?
OK.
So, what I'm
outlining is the steps
that you would use to prove
that this is homogeneous.
I'm doing it for
the closed case.
Now the point is that if we
can do it for the open case,
we'll prove that
the open metric is
what we want it to be--
homogeneous and isotropic.
And that's the only
criteria that we
have for goodness of a metric.
So, continuing with
the closed case
in mind, the first step
of doing this mapping,
to map some arbitrary
point to the origin,
is to first find its
x, y, z, w-coordinates,
its Cartesian coordinates.
Once we have the
Cartesian coordinates,
we know that in the
four-dimensional space
we can perform ordinary
euclidean rotations.
Rotations in four
dimensions [INAUDIBLE],
not three dimensions.
And even rotations
in three dimensions
are not all that simple, but
nonetheless in principle,
we know how to do rotations
in four dimensions.
And we know what
we're trying to do
in the four-dimensional picture.
We're trying to
rotate this point
to the origin of our
coordinate system.
And the origin of our
coordinate system-- the way
we've done this mapping-- is
to make w equals capital R,
w equal to its maximum
value, the center
of our coordinate system.
That's where psi was
equal to 0, and now
where our new variable
little r is equal to 0.
So we'd like to map this point,
whatever it is, to the point
where w has a maximum value,
and the other coordinates all
vanish.
So we can do that.
We can find a rotation
that does that.
It's not even unique,
because you can always
rotate about the final axis.
But in any case, we imagine
that we can do that.
And that's step two-- is
to find the right rotation.
And a general rotation is
a linear transformation,
so you can write it as x prime,
y prime, z prime, w prime,
as a four vector,
is equal to some 4
by 4 rotation matrix times
the original four coordinates.
So an equation of
this form would
describe a
four-dimensional rotation.
And we in particular want the
four-dimensional rotation which
maps-- maybe I'll write it as a
similar matrix equation-- what
we want is that the matrix,
when it operates on x0, y0, z0,
and w0, which remember are
just the four coordinates
that correspond to
our original point,
r0, theta0, phi0, we want
this to map into 0, 0, 0,
r, which is the four-dimensional
description of the origin
of our new coordinate system.
And then finally, step
three is the obvious one.
Once we've found the
transformation that
maps to the origin,
now we just go back
to our original
angular coordinates.
So, now we set r prime
equal to the radius function
of x prime, y prime,
z prime, and w prime.
And this just means
the r-coordinate--
that corresponds to
those four euclidean
coordinates and similarly
for the other variables.
Theta prime is
the theta function
of x prime, y prime,
z prime, and w prime.
And phi prime is equal
to the phi function.
All these are
functions that we know.
I just don't want to
write them out explicitly,
because that's a lot of work.
So it's phi of x prime, y
prime, z prime, w prime.
So now with the three
steps, we have our mapping.
We could start with an arbitrary
point, perform the rotation,
and then calculate the
angular variables again.
Ok, do people understand
what I'm talking about here?
Oh good.
OK.
And the good things is I
promise I won't make you do it.
And I've never done it
either, to be honest.
But it's obvious
that we can do it.
And if we can do this, this
would prove and especially
demonstrate homogeneity.
It would be a mapping that
would map an arbitrary
point to the origin, proving
that, that arbitrary point was
equivalent to the origin as
far as the metric is concerned.
And now my claim, I
mean, I'm not really
going to prove this
either, but it's
a claim that could be verified
by going through things.
And it also seems
highly plausible--
that if you looked at
each of these steps--
these are all just
algebra steps,
algebraic equations--
that they would work just
as well for negative k
as they will for positive k.
And by doing these same
series of manipulations
for negative k, you
would prove that
the Robertson-Walker
metric for negative k
is homogeneous,
which is our goal.
We already know it's isotropic.
If we can prove it's
homogeneous, we're home free.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
Yes?
PROFESSOR: Does the necessity
of placing the origin at r,
like big R, on w is that
just because that thing is
expanding?
Or-- I'm kind of having
trouble understanding
why it wouldn't be
just straight 0s.
Like, why there's that
[INAUDIBLE] value [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK, the question
is why does the origin look
like this as opposed
to just being all 0s.
The answer is that all 0s
is not even in our space.
Because, remember the
space we're interested in
is the surface of the sphere.
And the surface of
the sphere obeys
x squared plus y squared
plus z squared plus w squared
equals r squared.
So if all the
coordinates were 0,
it's not part of
our space at all.
So we're using this
four-dimensional space,
the embedding space,
to make things simple.
But in the end,
we're only interested
in the three-dimensional
surface.
So the origin of our
coordinate system
for that
three-dimensional surface
had better be in the
three-dimensional surface.
So of course, other choices
we could have made--
we could have put it anywhere
we want on the surface.
Choosing to put it where
w has its maximum value
is just an arbitrary convention.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you were saying
that most metrics are not
homogeneous?
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah.
Sure.
Most metrics are
not homogeneous.
Most objects are not around.
AUDIENCE: When we're
doing this math
to show that the
Robertson-Walker was
homogeneous, it
didn't seem that we
use the exact form of the
Robertson-Walker metric
at all in it.
We just said, it is
possible to do these--
PROFESSOR: Well, no.
We did use the form when
we made this rotation.
We used the form that, in
the euclidean formulation,
we knew that it was
rotationally invariant.
And the rotational invariance
in the euclidean formulation
is homogeneity and
guarantees homogeneity,
but it's a special property.
If it was ellipsoidal
shaped instead of spherical,
when you rotated it, it
would not be invariant.
If it had any bumps or
lumps when you rotated it,
it would not be invariant.
Yes, Aviv.
AUDIENCE: I feel like there
should be a fourth step where
you show that the metric doesn't
change forms [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
We do need to know the
metric does not change form,
but I think we do
have a guaranteed--
maybe we should've
said some words.
I don't think it's really
a fourth step in the sense
that I don't think it
requires anymore algebra.
But the point is that we know
that the metric is invariant,
that the four-dimensional
metric is
invariant under this
rotation, which was really
the only non-trivial step.
And otherwise, besides
the rotation, all we did
is we went from the
r theta phi variables
to the utility
euclidean variables,
and then we went back from
the euclidean variables
to the r theta phi variables.
But we already know how to
go from euclidean variables
to r theta phi variables, and
it results in that metric.
And it will still result
in that metric when,
if a prime is on all
of the coordinates.
AUDIENCE: So you don't
have to say, like,
suppose we have a
[INAUDIBLE] byproduct.
And do the mapping,
figure out what
the ds squared is in
terms of r theta phi
to show that it's the same?
Do we have to do
that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK, the
question is do we
have to explicitly
show that ds squared is
the same for the
new variables as it
was for the old variables.
We certainly want to be
convinced that that's true,
and we certainly want to have
an argument which convinces us.
But I would claim
that if you think
about what underlies
these steps,
I only gave a schematic
description of them.
If you think about what
underlies these steps,
I think it's implicit that
the form of the metric
is what we had.
The form of the metric that
we had was completely dictated
by the transformation,
which expressed
r theta and phi in
terms of x, y, z, and w.
And as long as you know
the metric in x, y, z,
and w, and that's the
euclidean metric both before
and after our
rotation, then when you
use the same equations
to go from x, y, z,
w to r, theta, and phi, you'll
always get the same metric.
So I think we are
guaranteed by this process
to get a metric for
our new variables, r
prime, theta prime,
and phi prime,
which has exactly the same
form as the original metric.
Because it's the same
calculation again.
The only difference is that
this time the variables
all have primes on them.
And the crucial step, the
step that was nontrivial,
is the fact that this rotation
did not change the metric.
That's where the
homogeneity was built in,
that we started with
a sphere that we
knew was rotationally invariant.
And this whole calculation
just extracts that homogeneity
that we built in
from the beginning.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For k negative,
it's r squared over k,
so is r negative?
PROFESSOR: No.
r is still positive
when expressed
in terms of x, y, z, and w.
Let me think if I can show that.
I'll show that next time.
It's a little involved,
but it will be positive.
I might add that if we
look at this formula
and ask what's going
on, what's going on--
we don't necessarily need to
know this-- but what's going on
is that in going from the
closed case to the open case,
k goes from positive to negative
and therefore square root of k
becomes imaginary.
But psi also becomes imaginary.
To describe the relationship
between the closed metric
and the open metric,
if you're using psi,
you have to say that
for the closed metric,
you'll use real values of
psi, and for the open metric,
you'll use imaginary
values of psi.
And that makes r real and
makes this formula work.
And you could also then
see how this formula works.
If psi is assigned
imaginary values,
then deep psi
squared is negative,
so this negative sign
cancels that negative sign,
and you again get a
positive definite metric.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So how can we choose
the imaginary [INAUDIBLE]
of sine and psi.
Is that just to reflect or
is that a choice that we're
making for our model?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
The question is why
do we choose to use
the imaginary value of psi.
And the answer is
perhaps that I failed
to state all the conditions
we're interested in when I said
what properties we want
this metric to have.
We want the metric
that we're seeking
to be homogeneous and
isotropic, as we said.
What we didn't say,
but what I kind of
had in the back of my
mind as an assumption,
is that the metric should
also be positive definite.
You can construct
other metrics which
are homogeneous and isotropic
but not positive definite.
In fact, you would
if you let psi
be real and let k be negative.
You'd have a negative definite
metric, which would still
be homogeneous and isotropic.
So to enforce all
three properties,
you have to use
some imagination.
And the easiest way to do
it is to write the metric
in the magical form where you
can just let k go to minus k,
and that's the
Robertson-Walker form here.
And if you write it this way,
when you let k go to minus k,
it becomes negative
definite, and you
have to scratch your head.
And if you really clever,
you might say, well,
if I assign
negative-- excuse me,
if I assign imaginary
values to psi,
it'll become positive
definite again.
That works, but it's
less straightforward.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do we want it
to be positive definite
so that it's visible?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
We want it to be positive
definite so it's visible.
AUDIENCE: Is there any way we
can have a negative definite
for a multidimensional
space that's reflects
a 3D positive definite space?
PROFESSOR: Is there anyway
in higher dimensional space
or something that we can have
it maybe have mixed signs
or be negative.
Well in fact, we
will see shortly,
because we're going
to add in time,
time will occur with
the opposite sign,
and it will not be
positive definite anymore.
But that will nonetheless
correspond to real physics.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So why do we have to force
that ds squared into spaces?
PROFESSOR: Because now we
are talking only about space,
and certainly for our
universe, space is positive.
Now, I might add since
you brought this up,
that in relativity, there's no
clear distinction between space
and time, so you might
wonder why should I
be saying that space is
positive and time is negative.
And perhaps I'm
oversimplifying a bit when
I say that space is positive
and time is negative.
But what is a requirement
for general relativity
to match our universe, and
therefore a requirement that we
impose on the general
relativity theory,
is that the metric have three
positive eigenvalues and one
negative eigenvalue.
And that's how it's
described, and that's
called the signature of
the metric-- the number
of positive eigenvalues and the
number of negative eigenvalues.
And reality clearly has--
well, I shouldn't say clearly.
String theory is
more dimensions--
but to describe our
macroscopic world, clearly,
we have quantities
that we intuitively
identify as three space
dimensions in one time
dimension.
And the metric
that describes that
is a metric whose signature
is three positive eigenvalues
and one negative eigenvalue.
Although, some people
reverse the sign conventions
and say it's three
negative and 1 positive,
which works just as well.
You can define the
metric with either sign.
But this is the one
that we're using,
the one that corresponds
to space being positive.
OK, any other questions?
OK.
In that case, let's move onward.
What did I want to
talk about next?
OK.
I wanted to write
on the blackboard
a statement which came about
earlier due to questioning
but hasn't been written on
the blackboard yet, which
is that there's a
theorem which says
that the most general possible
three-dimensional metric, which
is homogeneous and
isotropic, is this space.
So any three-dimensional,
homogeneous, and isotropic
space can be described by
the Robertson-Walker metric.
We are not going to prove
this, but it is a theorem.
If you want to see a proof,
there's a proof, for example,
in Steve Weinberg's gravitation
and cosmology textbook.
And in a lot of other
books, I'm sure.
But we'll take it for granted.
These are certainly the only
homogeneous and isotopic spaces
that we know how to construct.
And in fact, it's the
only ones that exist.
Now, I emphasize
that if the space is
homogeneous and
isotropic, obviously
the metric does not
have to look exactly
like that, because you can
choose different coordinates.
We could take these coordinates
and make some arbitrary
transformation and make the
metric look incredibly ugly.
It would still be a homogeneous
and isotropic space.
But the claim is that any
homogeneous and isotropic space
can be written in metric
that looks exactly
like this with a proper
choice of coordinates.
OK.
Next thing I want to discuss
is the size of these universes.
Size in the generalized
sense of, actually
the question of
whether it's positive--
whether it's infinite or finite.
Notice that our
closed universe, one
can see from the embedding
in four euclidean dimensions,
is finite.
The surface of a
sphere is finite.
And one can also see it
from the form of the metric,
although one has to think a
little bit about how exactly
it works.
If we start at the origin
and let r get bigger,
clearly something
funny's going to happen
when r is equal to 1 over
the square root of k.
That is, when kr
squared is equal to 1,
this metric will
become singular.
If one goes back to the angular
description in terms of psi,
it's clearer what's
going on there.
When kr squared is 1, that's
exactly where sine psi is one.
And that just means
you've reached
the equator of your sphere.
Quick picture.
Size measured from the w-axis.
The equator corresponds
to sine psi equals 1.
And then if you continue,
psi gets bigger up to pi,
but r starts getting
smaller again.
So r is double
valued in the sense
that there are two latitudes
at which r has the same value--
one of the northern
hemisphere and one
in the southern hemisphere.
But in any case, r starts from
0, goes to some maximum value,
and then goes back to 0.
Everything is finite.
And one could integrate
and find the total volume,
and it's finite.
And I think it was or will
be a homework problem where
you do exactly that integral
at the volume of a closed
universe.
On the other hand, if k--
let's first set it equal to 0.
If k is 0, we have here just
the euclidean metric and polar
coordinates
describing flat space.
And there's no limit on r. r
can become as large as you want.
You can hypothesize
that space somehow ends,
but we don't believe-- we
don't know of any end to space.
And there are-- in any case, a
precise way you could describe
what it would mean for space
to end in general relativity
and the usual postulates of
general relativity is that ,
that doesn't happen-- that space
doesn't just have an arbitrary
end.
So the flat case is an infinite
space when k is equal to 0.
It's just an infinite
euclidean space.
Similarly, if k is
negative, then nothing funny
happens as r increases.
So there's no reason not to
let r increase to infinity.
Anything else would just
be putting in an arbitrary
wall into space
without any motivation
for believing that
such a wall is there.
And one has to remember that
r is not physical distance.
So the fact that r
can go to infinity
doesn't necessarily
make the space infinite,
but you can calculate
physical distance.
We can calculate the
physical distance
from the origin to the
radius r, and we get that
just by integrating the metric.
The metric tells us what
the actual physical length
is for an infinitesimal segment.
That's what the metric
meant in the first place.
So the integral that we'd be
doing of an a of t out front,
and then we'll be integrating
dr prime over the square root
of 1 minus kr prime
squared from 0 up to r.
Remember k is negative.
So this is a positive quantity
under the square root.
It's not going to cause any
problems by vanishing on us.
And this is an integral,
which is in fact, doable.
And it's just equal
to, still the a
of t in front, which I think
I left out in the notes,
times an inverse hyperbolic
cinch of the square root
of minus kr over
square root of minus k.
Remember k is negative.
See these are all square
roots of positive numbers.
And that cinch function,
the inverse cinch
can get to be as
large as one wants
by letting r be as
large as one wants.
It grows without bound.
And that means the physical
distance grows without bound
as r grows to infinity.
And it grows faster
than linear, I think.
I take that back.
I'm not sure.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I guess
I'm still confused
because r is sine of psi
over square root of k,
so sine psi is bounded
by 1 and negative 1,
so if we're letting r
go to infinity, how--
PROFESSOR: That formula only
works for the closed case.
r equals sine psi over root k.
We can apply it to the open case
if we let psi become imaginary.
But then the bounds that
you said no longer apply.
The sine of an
imaginary variable
is, in fact, the cinch
of a real variable.
OK?
Next thing I want
to point out is
that the
Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevski
geometry that you did a
homework problem about or it
was an extra credit problem,
so some of you did not.
But we talked about the
Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevski
geometry.
That really is just an
open Robertson-Walker, RW
Robertson-Walker metric,
but in two space dimensions.
But it's completely analogous
to the Robertson-Walker metric
in three space dimensions
that we're talking about here.
So you might recall that
Felix Klein construction
looked very complicated.
That's because of the
coordinates that he used.
Those coordinates might be
simple from some point of view,
but from the point of view
of illustrating homogeneity,
they're very
complicated coordinates.
And anyway, to physicists,
the Robertson-Walker open
coordinate system is familiar,
and the Felix Klein coordinate
system is not.
OK.
If there are no
further questions
about these spatial metrics, the
next thing I want to talk about
is adding time to the picture.
Because in the end,
we're going to be
interested in a
spacetime metric,
because that's what
general relativity is
all about-- spacetime metrics.
OK.
Everything is going to
hinge on an important fact
from special relativity, which
we are going to assume but not
prove, because most
you have had courses
about special
relativity elsewhere.
And for those you who
have not, you can either,
if you wish, read an
appendix to lecture
notes five, in which the fact
that I'm about to show you
is derived, or you
could just assume it.
Whichever you prefer, depending
on how much time you have.
This is not a course
about special relativity.
You're not required
to learn how to derive
the fact that I'm
about to write.
And what I'm about
to write starts
with a definition
given any two events.
An event is a
point in spacetime.
Snapping my finger-- this
clearly speaking event.
It happens at a certain
place in a certain time.
And every real events occupies
some small volume of spacetime.
An ideal event is a
point in spacetime.
And we'll be talking
about ideal events.
Which, our model, as I said,
has points in spacetime.
So given any two
events, one can talk
about a separation
between those events.
And they will be separated
in both space and time,
although either one
of those could be 0.
But they're not both 0,
or it's the same event.
And it's possible to define
an interesting quantity, which
is the difference between
the x-coordinates of the two
events.
This will be the separation
between two events, which I'll
call a and b, and xa and
xb are the x-coordinates
of those two events.
And probably you all
have enough imagination
to guess that ya and yb are
the y-coordinates of those two
events.
And za and zb are the
z-coordinates of those events.
And now here's a surprising one,
if you haven't already seen it.
We're going to have
minus c squared
times ta minus tb squared.
Now, this is all in
special relativity.
I maybe should clarify.
We haven't gotten to general
relativity or cosmology yet.
But we need to
understand something
from special relativity first.
So in special relativity,
it's natural to define
that interval
between two events.
And the magical
property, which is
why we define this integral
in the first place,
is that if we had two
different inertial observers,
we could calculate
how the coordinates
as seen by one
observer are related
to the coordinates as seen
by the other observer.
And that's called the
Lorentz transformation.
And one finds that this
particular quantity
will have exactly the same
value to both observers always.
The two observers will, in
general, find different values
for every one of the
four quantities here.
But when the four quantities
are added up with a minus sign
in front of the time
term, the calculations
would show that you get the same
value for inertial observers.
So this quantity is
called Lorentz invariant,
meaning it's invariant under
Lorentz transformations.
And it makes it a
very important thing
to talk about
because in the end,
physical things have to
be essentially Lorentz
invariant because the laws of
physics are Lorentz invariant.
The laws of physics are the
same in all Lorentz frames,
so ultimately they have to
involve quantities, which
have some simple
relationship from one Lorentz
frame to another.
OK now, we'd still like to
have a clearer notion, I think,
of what this quantity means.
It's defined by that
equation and principle,
but it would be nice if we
had some understanding of what
it means.
And I think the
easiest way to describe
what it means is to
look at special frames,
even though the important
feature of this quantity
is that it has the same
numerical value in all frames.
So the numerical value is
the same in all frames,
but some frames make it
easier to interpret it.
That's what I'm claiming.
So, what that frame is depends
on the value of s squared,
or at least the sine of it.
For sab squared
greater than 0, which
means it's dominated
by the spatial terms
there, because those
are the positive ones.
And therefore, the separation
is called spacelike.
Some books put a hyphen between
space and like and some don't.
I don't.
And there's a theorem that
says that if the separation
between two events is
spacelike, there always
exists a Lorentz frame, an
inertial frame, in which
the two events happen
simultaneously.
Backwards E is a
There Exists symbol.
Then there exists
an inertial frame
in which a and b
are simultaneous.
In that frame, we
could look at what
that formula tells
us sab squared is.
Since they're
simultaneous, ta equals tb,
and therefore the last
term does not contribute.
So in that frame, s squared
is just xa minus xb squared
plus ya minus yb squared
plus za minus zb squared.
And we know what that is.
That's just the euclidean
length, the euclidean distance
between the two points.
So, in this frame,
sab squared is
just equal to the distance
between events squared.
Or you take the square
root because they're
positive numbers.
You could say sab is equal to
the distance between the two
events.
So when sab squared
is positive, sab
is just the distance
between the two events
in the frame in which
they're simultaneous.
If sab squared is not positive,
it could be negative or 0.
Let me go to the
negative case first.
For sab squared less than
0, for it to be less than 0,
it means that this expression
is dominated by the time term
because that's
the negative term.
And therefore the separation
is called timelike.
And again, there's a theorem.
The theorem says that if the
separation between two events
is timelike, there exists
a frame in which it
happened in the same location.
If they're at the
same location, we
could again look at
that equation that
defines sab squared
and ask what form
does it take in
this special frame
where the two events
are the same location.
That means the first
three terms are all 0
because-- same location.
It means in that frame,
sab squared is negative,
and it's just minus c
squared times the time
separation squared.
So in that frame, sab
squared is equal to minus
c squared tau ab
squared, where tau ab
is just equal to
the time separation.
So when sab squared is
negative, its meaning
is as minus c squared times the
square of the time separation
in the frame where the
two events happened
at the same place.
Now, this notion of the
two events happening
at the same place has a
particularly simple intuition
if the two events that
we're talking about happen
on the same object, like two
flashes of the same strobe
if that strobe is moving
at a constant velocity.
Otherwise, all bets are off.
But if that strobe is moving
at a constant velocity
so that the frame of the
strobe is an inertial frame,
then the frame of the
strobe is, in fact,
the frame in which
the two events
happened at the same place.
They both happened at the bulb
of the strobe light, which
in the frame of the
strobe is just one point.
So this time interval, which
the sab squared measures,
is simply the time interval as
measured by the object itself,
is measured by an observer
following the strobe.
And if we place the strobe by
a person with a wristwatch,
this notion of time, which
is called proper time,
is simply the time measured
by the person's wristwatch.
A clock that follows the
object so that anything that
happened to that object
happens at the same location.
So if events happen
to the same object,
ta ab is just the time interval
measured by that object.
And as you give these things
names for the spacelike case,
sab is often called the proper
distance between the events,
and ta ab is the proper time
interval between the events.
OK.
One more case to do,
which is, if it's not
positive or negative,
there's only one remaining
choice, which is
it's got to be 0.
If sab squared is 0,
then again looking back
at the original definition, it
means that the spatial piece
is equal to minus c squared
times the time piece
so that they all cancel.
If you think about it, that's
precisely the statement
that these two
events are located
in just the right situation so
the light beam that leaves one
will just arrive at the other.
Because it says that some
of the first three terms,
which is the
distance squared, is
equal to c squared times
the time interval squared.
And that just says
that something
travels at the speed of light.
It could travel that distance
in that time and go from point a
to point b or vice versa.
Only one or the other, not both.
But it's always
one or the other.
So, for that reason, the
interval is called lightlike.
And it means that a light
pulse can travel from a to b,
or I could have
interchanged a or b.
Everything is squared.
It doesn't matter
which is which.
Now, there's a
peculiar thing here.
You would think that if a light
pulse can travel from a to b,
there would still be
some relevant measure
to how far apart a and b are.
However, what we're
basically seeing here
is that if a and b are
lightlike separated,
in any given reference frame you
could talk about what the time
interval is and that will be
equal to the space interval
up to a factor of c.
But if we imagine
looking at this
at different frames,
different inertial frames,
these two points
can get arbitrarily
close together or
arbitrarily far apart,
depending on what frame
we look at them in.
There is no Lorentz
invariant measure
of how far apart they look.
The Lorentz invariant-- the
only Lorentz invariant measure
simply tells us that
they're lightlike
related to each other.
And this leads to some
very peculiar issues
when you try to prove rigorous
theorems about relativity.
You can't really say whether
two lightlike points, two
lightlike separated
points are close or far.
Because there's no real meaning
for them to be close or far.
OK.
Let me just say one more fact
about special relativity,
and then we'll quit for today
and come back on Thursday
and then talk about
how to extend this
into general relativity.
OK, there's a question.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just really quick.
For the Lorentz
invariant to equal to 0,
does that mean that
the objects should
be moving at the speed of
light relative to each other?
Is it like that?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The question is, if the
separation is lightlike,
s squared is 0.
Does that mean that
these two objects
are moving at the speed of
light relative to each other
or something like that?
No, it does not.
It only talks about
their positions.
It doesn't say anything about
the motion of these objects.
It's only a statement about
their x and t-coordinates
at some instant.
OK, let me still write
one more equation
on the blackboard to kind of
finish the special relativity
part of the discussion.
In the end, we are
interested in the metric.
And what makes a
metric a little bit
different from a
distance function
is that metrics refer to
infinitesimal distances.
So we're going to want to know
the infinitesimal form of that.
And it's obvious,
so it's nothing
to make a big deal about.
But I think it's worth
writing on the blackboard.
The infinitesimal
form of that equation
is that ds squared is equal
to dx squared plus dy squared
plus dz squared minus c squared
dt squared where dxdy, dz
and dt are the
infinitesimal coordinate
differences between two events.
And it's in that form that we'll
be beginning from and taking
off into the world
of general relativity
and the metric of general
relativistic spacetimes.
So we'll continue
with this on Thursday.